all right so today we're gonna discuss
the five symptoms or ways of knowing
you're consuming too much protein okay
number one foamy urine okay this is a
situation where you have protein
spilling off into the urine
normally you don't have a lot of protein
in the urine you shouldn't have anything
maybe just this very small amount so if
there's protein in the urine it can
become foamy now if you have protein the
urine potentially it could be liver
disease but it could also mean you're
just consuming too much protein cut it
back and see if it goes away because
your kidneys actually filter about a
hundred and eighty liters of fluid every
single day I mean think about it
maybe you consumed two liters of fluid
your kidneys are filtering it all day
long so it's filtering the blood over
and over and over and only a tiny 2% of
it is excreted as urine so there's it's
very very efficient so if you have too
much protein you can overload the
kidneys overload the liver and it can
spill off into the urine number two
gout okay now usually gout is a liver or
kidney problem okay but if you're adding
more protein to it you can get an
incomplete protein breakdown and
generate too much uric acid and create
these gout crystals number three
decrease appetite okay that could be one
of the symptoms and before fluid
retention or edema you may see a little
swelling or even in your ankles some
pitting edema you press into your ankle
and it kind of leaves a dent in there
and number five
fatigue okay so these are the five
symptoms of consuming too much protein
now let's say for example you're on one
meal a day all mad and you're fasting
okay and you're eating more protein than
you should well what happens is like you
have if you're eating one meal a day you
have like 23 hours to fast and you have
so much repair going on you can probably
get away with it very easily without
creating any problem to the kidney or a
liver because the benefits of that
fasting are huge
just for in repair in general so if
you're just eating that one meal you
could do a good amount of protein more
than usual but typically it's good to
consume a moderate amount of protein not
too little not too much just an average
amount between like 3 to 6 maybe up to 8
ounces per meal okay depending on your
your age depending on your digestive
system depending how big you are okay
but this is the range that seems to work
out best alright I'll see you in the
next video
so if you're enjoying this content go
ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it